it's not what you did son it's who you
did it to nobody but nobody is jungbaek
welcome to your weekly ticket
work-from-home edition I'm just trying
out hats at this point I don't know what
to do with my hair anymore Lionsgate
continues to shift its upcoming film
schedule the fourth installment of the
John wick franchise John wick four has
moved a year later from its May 21st
2021 release to May 27th 2022 that means
no Keanu Day remember it was supposed to
come out on the same day as the matrix
oh well one kyon whole year and now
taking over the previous John wick for
release date is the Chris Rock samuel
l.jackson horror film spiral the saw
reboot is now expected to hit theaters
on May 21st 2021 also the new
live-action Transformers film now has a
release date Paramount Pictures has
announced the film will open in theaters
on June 24 2022 and animated
transformers prequel is also in the
works from Oscar winner Josh Cooley who
wrote and directed Toy Story for the
animated film is said to be a prequel to
the live-action Transformers movies and
will further explore the origin story as
well as the relationship between Optimus
Prime and Megatron ah a live-action
remake of Hercules is in development at
Disney Joe and Anthony Russo the
filmmakers behind the Avengers endgame
and infinity war are set to produce it
and while no other details are available
at this time plenty of you had a lot to
say about casting on Twitter let's see
what you got some flicks Werfel 6 says
I'm still very much into the idea of
Johnny Depp playing Hades in the
Hercules remake yeah he likes wearing
prosthetics though I throw some
prosthetics on him and you're good to go
hopeless moon tweets please let ariana
play the role of Megara in the hercules
live-action movie Angel itch tweets hey
Russo brothers I found your Hercules for
their Hercules live action and they've
got a photo of Tom Holland alright first
off who would you cast in the Hercules
live-action film and secondly we can all
agree that they need to get Danny DeVito
to return
as Phil right like who else come on so
by now maybe you're running out of
things to watch and you're looking for
some recommendations well I've got great
news because I have a very special guest
today screen junkies own Roxie stryer
with a recommendation Roxie what do you
got so this is a recommendation that I
feel honored to give because I am about
to make your guys quarantine complete
your viewing experience will be complete
because this is the best movie that I
saw last year but it was also the most
underrated movie that people just simply
didn't go see and that is the peanut
butter Falcon it did get some buzz
around Oscar time especially with Shia
LaBeouf and Zack got sagen actually
presenting an award but this movie is
more than worth your time it's got so
much heart and soul to it and especially
in a time where none of us can go on a
journey it's about a guy who is trying
to break free to go on a journey and is
able to do so it's so beautiful Tyler
Nelson and Michael Schwartz who direct
and co-wrote it together are going to be
people to look out for I'm telling you
that their names are names that you want
to remember because they write something
unique it's different and in a time
where we have so many movies that hit
the same beats I never knew it was gonna
happen next if you're a wrestling fan as
well mick foley jake the snake' some
great great cameos and bruce dern isn't
it and he elevates everything so the
peanut butter Falcon I'm telling you
this movie is worth your time oh my god
such a high recommendation incredible
but I want to hear from you Carol what
is your recommendation easy
recommendation is John wick because you
can watch it for free listen if you
haven't seen John wick now is your
chance if you have seen John wick hey we
get to watch John wick again for free
because right now Lionsgate is going to
be streaming it live in conjunction with
Fandango it's gonna be on the movieclips
youtube channel at 6 p.m. on Friday you
can join a bunch of people watching it
live if you don't know what John wick is
about it was about a man who loses
everything and seeks revenge
in just the most brutal and amazing ways
it has Keanu Reeves as John wick he did
so many of his own stunts it's such an
impressive watch and there's three of
them currently so if you love John wick
one you've got more VIP movies to watch
during the quarantine so you're speaking
my language I am obsessed with John wick
and there is no better word in the
English language than free so when you
combine John wick and free you a hundred
percent have this guy alright well thank
you so much Roxy make sure to check out
her YouTube channel that just had a
momentous celebration right 20,000
subscribers she's really doing it baby's
first YouTube channel so check it out
youtube.com slash Roxy's drier blankie
thank you simple thank you for having me
kale available to watch at home today is
the lodge how would you feel about going
to the mountains for Christmas with
grace she really wants to get to know
you guys during a family retreat to a
remote winter cabin over the holidays a
father is forced to abruptly to perper
work leaving his two children in the
care of his new girlfriend grace
isolated and alone
a blizzard traps them inside the lodge
as terrifying events some inspectors
from Grace's dark past also available to
watch on Fandango now is Gretel and
Hansel
tell the fairy tale again it's too scary
you know start seeing things that aren't
there when their mother descends into
madness siblings Gretel and Hansel must
fend for themselves in the dark and
unforgiving woods hungry and scared they
stumble upon a bounty of food left
outside of an isolated home once they're
invited inside by the seemingly friendly
owner the children soon suspect that her
generous but mysterious behavior is part
of a sinister plan to do them harm
Gretel and Hansel is the third film from
director oz Perkins whose previous works
include the black coats daughter and I'm
the pretty thing that lives in the house
all right well that is it for today let
us know what you'll be watching or if
you'll be watching the lodge or Gretel
and Hansel I'm Kayla nonnamous and I'll
see you next week
[Music]